conjoint alain babineau policiers de la
grc la retraite conseiller au centre de
recherche action aussi sur les relations
raciales en matière de profilage racial
et monsieur babineau bonjour bonjour ma
douce mc oui bonjour alors la police de
repentigny dit avoir reçu nous donner en
fait des constats autant à des jeunes
blanca des jeunes noirs est la police se
défend d'avoir fait preuve de
discrimination dans ce dossier là vous
en pensez quoi de votre côté et crise et
sur la façon dont les jeunes ont
rapporté l'incident et puis il ya même
vidéo qui a été pris ça semble être mort
paiement de discrétion de la part des
policiers au niveau de l'application des
règlements donc vous êtes en fait que le
règlement était là mais que les
policiers auraient pu prendre leur
pouvoir discrétionnaire pour donner
seulement un avertissement exactement
ras le bol ici aux côtés on n'est pas
obligé de donner des idées des années
mais sa lancée on veut à chaque fois
qu'on a un telle innovation un cri
jeunes écoutaient une relation de
l'érosion la police neil communauté
noire les jeunes en particulier très
tendu alors c'est raisonnable pour les
policiers d'être au courant de cette de
cette relation là et puis d'essayer
autant possible d'améliorer d'améliorer
les relations écriront part de près de
12000 dollars de code frais pour des
jeunes meurent aux alentours de 18 ans
et deux mains de jeunes qui sont des
démineurs alors c'est très très sérieux
et c'est pas la première fois qu'il a
pas les europe à tignes est accusé comme
ça le profilage racial
il ya du gros travail disait la
directrice de la police de repentigny
pour tenter de créer des ponts avec les
communautés alors vous dit en fait que
d'y aller avec des avertissements
ça aiderait justement à créer de
meilleurs liens avec les communautés
acte est tout ce que les policiers
peuvent faire pour essayer d'améliorer
les relations entre la communauté et les
services de police
donnez de l'historique de ces relations
sont très tendues comme je le disais
votre mari ni au niveau du profilage
racial peut aider et puis comme je vous
dis les jeunes hommes vu quelques
minutes après l'arrêt de l'intervention
d'autres jeunes blacks qui jouaient du
basketball et la police la police est
arrivée
et puis leur a parlé et plus les jeunes
sont partis sans contravention alors
parce que les jeunes noirs ont demandé
au jeune black sea ray le reçu les
conventions puis les jeunes lui ont dit
non alors il ya quand même des choses
qu'on doit discuter
la porte est ouverte on est prêt à
discuter avec eux les services de police
repenti et puis l'idée derrière tout ça
c'est d'améliorer dagne aurait des
relations c'est une petite communauté
c'est une grande ville devra pas se dit
quand même il ya quand même une vue
communautaire c'est assez large qui
grandit au niveau des personnes assises
et et puis on veut que tout le monde
soit traité d'une façon équitable se
sentent bien
repenti nis en serbie no vous est
conseillé au centre de recherche action
sur les relations raciales coup et vous
êtes aussi un ancien policier de la grc
coux et ces amendements sont donnés onze
mille doses mais dollars à des jeunes
comme ça qu'est ce que peut faire la
pole et c'est ce qu'elle peut faire un
espèce de mea culpa et retiré ses
amendements ce que c'est possible assaut
lancé sur sa sera ce soir au niveau de
la police puis au niveau 2 du procureur
la sauce et leur discrétion oblige les
gens qui devront s'ils veulent contester
mais nous on veut aller alors au delà de
son veut améliorer la relation entre les
policiers la communauté noire participe
t profilage racial
on l'a documenté ici au cra depuis dix
ans à repenser ni ya eu des bons peut
elle d'accord tu as eu des choses qui
ont été ses vues que ça se passe ainsi
de faire pour améliorer la situation
mais ça va au delà au delà de simplement
des deux de 2,2 de faire les prend et
puis de faire des barbecues ou des
choses comme ça on veut vraiment que des
mesures concrètes pour que les citoyens
noirs soient traités d'une façon
équitable est la même que toutes les
autres communautés vous donc un travail
en profondeur soit soit réalisé à ce
sujet la semaine non merci nous avons
parlé ce matin
or si beaucoup se moquerait au vent